how can we quickly find the cube root of
any perfect cube having less than seven
digits let's see say the cube root of
four thousand and ninety six to solve
this understanding of this table is very
important these are the cubes of numbers
from one to ten observe one thing that
all the units digits here are different
the second thing we need to know is that
the answer for the cube root of any four
five or six digit numbers will be two
digits long first we write the number
and from the right we take three digits
here we get two parts four and zero nine
six
now let us look at four and see between
which two cubes it really lies four lies
between one cubed and two cubed so the
tens digit is one we take the lower of
these two this was very simple now how
do we find the units digit if you look
at the table then there is only one
number whose cube has the units digit as
6 and that's 6. so the cube root of 4 0
9 6 is 16. using the same concept can
you tell me the cube root of this number
share your answers in the comment
section below